hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram and this is
the Ingram angle thanks for being with
us on a Friday night we examine Jill and
giselle's cruel power moves now
last year on October 14th here's how we
open the show
if you're thinking let's say of putting
an addition on your house maybe
renovating your kitchen
would you trust John fetterman to review
the bids and negotiate with the builders
and for that matter would you trust Joe
Biden to hire the best team to get the
job done
now if the answer to those questions is
no and I imagine it is for most of you
then neither man is really capable of
serving as a U.S senator or the U.S
president
at least not without a lot of people
making decisions for him and of course
this is exactly what's happening in both
cases
now here we are four months later sadly
Vindicated
wondering how two women closest to sick
men in declining Health can even live
with themselves
both Jill Biden and Gisele fetterman
know better than anyone how unfit to
serve their husbands are
now as bad as both men have looked and
sounded at various times to the rest of
us
imagine how bad they are behind closed
doors
but of course these women lie to
themselves and then they lie to us
how will this episode affect the
campaign and his upcoming schedule and
as soon as he's back he'll be back in
the trail I don't
your husband's cognitive abilities it's
ridiculous I mean Joe's on the phone
every single minute of the of the day
but I guess the Allure of power is too
great for compassion and common sense in
these cases because these women are
pushing their men beyond their limits
not out of a Devotion to their
constituents but due to these women own
desire for political power and Prestige
hey everybody it's John and Giselle as
you can see we hit a little bump on the
campaign Trail
um it was on Friday I just wasn't
feeling very well so I decided you know
what I need to get checked out so I went
to the hospital get checked out yes
because I was right as always
well one week after spending three days
in the hospital for a separate health
issue the Pennsylvania Senator had again
checked himself into Walter Reed now
while a lot of details aren't there yet
the media quickly moved to minimize the
medical developments themselves
this from Rolling Stone John fetterman
joins John McCain Donald Trump Patrick
Leahy and countless other politicians
who have sought treatment at a hospital
okay is that what's going on just
treatment at a hospital then there was
the effort to frame this as some Brave
and vulnerable act not anything that
would be considered Craven or a cruel
political calculation by a stage wife
and political nihilus
and at the White House briefing today
our favorite binder reader she chimed in
it was kind of a preemptive defense
against criticism of all those including
Biden himself who vouched for this poor
man's capabilities
millions of Americans as you all know go
untreated with depression every day
Senator fetterman did the right thing
and brave thing today today or just this
week by getting the help that he
definitely needs as the president and
first lady shared this morning they are
thinking about John Giselle and their
entire fetterman family today and they
they are grateful to senator fetterment
for being an example to this well so
many on the left refuse to acknowledge
fetterman's compromise Health six months
ago and despite the latest news they're
still holding the line
at least there are a few reporters
though who are out there and are
actually doing their jobs
he sees Dasha Burns was heavily
criticized by her fellow journals for
accurately describing fetterman's
situation after she conducted an
interview with him during the campaign
and today she reported new details about
fetterman's health
I did speak to a close senior aide of
his he said that we're looking at most
likely weeks that Senator fetterman will
be in inpatient care both the staff and
Veteran himself were surprised by the
severity of the depression for those
around him that it's been sort of
difficult to distinguish the symptoms of
the stroke from symptoms of depression
saying that sometimes you know it's hard
to know if he's not hearing you or if
he's just sort of being crippled by
depression and Social Anxiety
now rather than doing a reality check on
their previous defense of fetterman's
capabilities his office keeps digging
his office is so confident that
fetterman will make that full recovery
that they say the prospect of
resignation was quote never discussed
and is not on the table
how do they know for sure how can they
say that so confidently the poor man
he's suffering but don't worry we're all
confident they say a full recovery is
coming wait that does sound familiar
though or John fetterman he's still in
the hospital he is recovering he's
expected to make a full recovery Mr
Federman can make a full recovery some
Strokes take longer to recover from than
others and I'm really pleased that John
fetterman's doctors uh say his prognosis
is you know a full recovery now this was
wishful thinking at Best in an outright
lie at worst and today the honest few
around him obviously see that he's been
visibly struggling since he arrived in
Washington
let's face it fetterman has been through
so much and a Layman can tell that he
needs to be in full-time stroke rehab
and Recovery not in the pressure cooker
that is Washington D.C
but rather than seeing his recent
diagnosis as a wake-up call Gisele
fetterman is trying to use his diagnosis
as a political asset
after what he's been through in the past
year there's probably no one who wanted
to talk about his own health less than
John I'm so proud of him for asking for
help and getting the care he needs well
of course we're all happy he's getting
the care he needs he should be getting
help full-time
it's not a reason for shame a clinical
depression repression is serious and in
and of itself it's a serious condition
but especially coming after a stroke and
heart issues which you may remember
they'd hidden from the public
now by the way Giselle was the same
woman who called the NBC reporter Dasha
Burns openly ableist for questioning her
husband's physical and mental condition
during the campaign
so Giselle owes Ms Burns who was right
an apology
when people say politics is a cruel
business they're usually referring to
the politicians both battling each other
and the parties that they're in
Republican versus Democrat liberal
versus conservative
but in the case of fetterman and Biden
the cruelty comes at the hands of family
members who deny and lie in order to
ride the coattails of the men they prop
up for power and Status hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else